One light source in 3JS that attempts to simulate the surrounding bounced light
in the scene is the Hemisphere Light. Instead of this light having a particular
position, it's considered to fully surround the scene with light coming from
every direction. This is also how you can think of ambient light, but with a
difference. With a Hemisphere Light, you assign a light color to the top and a
different color to the bottom. Each object's normals determine the color of the
light it receives from this light source. If the normal points upward, the
light's color is the top color. If the surface normal points straight down, the
bottom color. Any direction in between gives a blend of these two colors. The
idea is that you can assign the top color to be something like the sky, the
bottom to be something like the surrounding terrain. It's basically a more
elaborate for of ambient lighting. When we talk about textures we'll see a more
involved version of this scheme called a Diffuse Map.